but in Canada it's mostly women and the
men they married that are now
technically trapped in their homes they
can't leave the country even if they
want for a better life because they're
in debt and might pay a mortgage into
their yeah and and that's the one thing
I've learned from interviewing so many
only fans bottles is realizing that
these chicks can make a bunch of money
but they will still be broke at 50 there
is no way they will not be because none
of them have plans literally none of
them what up guys welcome to the just
curly thing YouTube channel and welcome
to my reaction series before I start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way and
guys let's get this video to 2,000 likes
also while you're at it get yourself a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt today as
you guys know all of the treachery and
craziness in society really is linked to
women voting so let's take that away
immediately so today I am going to be
reacting to strong and Independent Women
are going broke um from Sandman mtow
channel so let's play the video s man
here this video was brought to you by a
donation from Terry he didn't give me a
topic so I wanted to share an experience
I had a while back helping a couple of
women dealing with their financial
issues unless you've been living under a
logger in your parents' basement then
you'll have noticed the crazy inflation
rate the last couple of years these two
women inherited millions of dollars from
their father before he passed away and
he never taught them about money because
he said their husband would take care of
it but they decided to go down the old
strong and independent route and not get
married and now inflation is nipping at
their cankles and they're worried about
what to do being that once upon a time I
was a financial advisor and then I've
solved the inflation Quagmire for myself
I figured I might as well play the part
of the White Knight and help them they
showed me what they were invested in and
it was mostly bonds cash and blue chip
dividen stocks the lowest of risk assets
but with low risks come low rewards on
top of that these days you have to earn
10% before tax per year on your money to
realistically keep up with inflation and
live in the west these women were
petrified of investing in high-risk
assets like Bitcoin and tax stocks then
it dawned on me so many widows and
strong independent women out there they
are going to get eaten alive by
inflation like a great big snake eating
its own tail or the old polish scarf
trick which asks the question how do you
make a scarf one foot longer the answer
of course is you cut a foot off one end
and sew it onto the other not to pick on
the Polish people but these days Poland
is one of the most successful economies
in Europe the scarf for snake is the
government printing money and devaluing
the daero of independent debutants to
pay for the services that they enjoy
thinking about this that's when I
realized that all the government goodies
that women get will come out of their
own savings and pensions how ironic is
that if you're like me you have two jobs
now one job herb jobs is to generate
enough income and earn it and the second
job is to manage your money and prevent
it from being stolen through money
printing most women I know like the ones
I mentioned just go to the bank and hire
a financial advisor that works on
commission or trailer fees the adviser
then puts them into something safe
because remember the financial company
collects 1 or 2% of year on management
fees so if they take a risky strategy
and the asset Falls by 50% they only get
half of the asset management fees they
would have gone if they just put it into
something safe they're incentivized to
play it safe with your money and let
inflation eat most of it away but in
Financial environment playing it safe
means you're living dangerously because
of how quickly your savings are being
devalued gas prices went up recently and
that's fueling even more inflation no
pun intended the central banks are now
screwed if they cut rates then we see
massive ass in inflation in stocks and
crypto and then people make money and
spend it into the economy thus inflation
and the general cost of living on things
like food goes up but if they raise
rates or keep them high then you see a
massive spike in consumers and
governments being unable to pay their
debts these two women I spoke to were
complaining about their okay wait so I
just want to clarify that I understand
this so basically he's saying the issue
with financial advisors is they make it
not risky for women or they they don't
do risky Investments so they can just
take their percentage in bounce but the
issue with that is then you leave most
of your money in the bank and the issue
with that is that inflation eats away at
your money and so it's interesting
because all the benefits that women are
getting are actually going to come out
of their savings and retirement so a
bunch of women will be credit card debts
don't ask me why you're in debt with
that much money and assets I'll discuss
why I think that inflation is going to
make a lot of women out there broke in a
moments but first let me tell everyone
about today's sponsor the red pill ring
robbed by government money printing
because they're afraid of taking risks
with their own money clown world show in
a world where having assets protects you
from inflation women are more risk
averse to their detriments two years ago
only 7% of women own crypto while 16% of
men dead with stocks 40% of men own them
and only 24% of women most women don't
want to work a second job by coming home
and managing their money they don't want
to be educated about it either they will
gladly pay a man to take care of it if
they don't have a husband that gives
many sleazy scammers the opportunity to
Swindle tons of single women out there
out of their money as investment
advisers as I was saying single women
are more financially fearful and risk
averse than men are they don't want to
own things that go up and down like a
palm tree and a hurricane I think that
the the elites get people away from the
assets they don't want them to own and
into the ones they do is by increasing
or decreasing the volatility cash has
the least volatility so people think
they're safe but in oh so he's saying if
people think that it's less volatile
they can therefore control it because
more people do it because it's safe
they're losing s or 8% a year as of late
and are just looking at a number instead
of what the number Buys so those two
women I help them buy some assets as a
test less than half of 1% of their
assets
and I put 1/3 into a Bitcoin ETF 1/3
into a big Tech ETF and 1/3 into
Canadian dividend ETFs many good
Canadian stocks are now paying 6 to 8%
dividends right now as their prices have
come down quite a bit I think people
have been dumping those stocks realizing
that even with such generous payouts
it's not enough to keep up with
inflation some people are saying we're
about to see deflation I don't see that
with more men than ever going on strike
and basically no longer working as much
if men check out workers short mean the
cost of Labor goes up and it's going to
be putting pressure on prices of
everything also for those stocks their
dividend income won't cover the cost of
inflation plus the banks here in Canada
and government don't want to see asset
deflation and are bringing in immigrants
to keep the housing bubble propped up by
creating housing shortages and the banks
are converting mortgages to 40 or 50e
loans the banks are letting people pay
the same amount of money when interest
rates were 2% as when they're now 6%
they just have to pay interest for an
extra decade or two to boot but in
candidates mostly women and the men they
married that are now technically trapped
in their homes they can't leave the
country even if they want for a better
life because they're in debt and might
pay a mortgage into their yeah and and
that's the one thing I've learned from
interviewing so many only fans models
realizing that these chicks can make a
bunch of money but they will still be
broke at 50 there is no way they will
not be because none of them have plans
literally none of them 7s or ' 80s
people thought that Financial repression
would be all about not allowing people
to buy foreign stocks or ass to protect
their wealth I think this is a different
flavor of it where you're stuck in a
failing State unable to leave because if
you do you go bankrupt and lose all the
equity in your house you won't even be
able to sell it because very few people
will be able to qualify to buy it at six
or seven or maybe 8% interest at current
prices when the world economic Forum
said you will own nothing and be happy
could this have actually been what they
meant that you'll never be able to pay
off your home loan and the bank will own
it to the day you die but you'll still
be happy because you think you're a
homeowner when technically you aren't
huh wow that is so interesting because
even when you own a home you don't own a
home wow that's the one thing about
about Sandman is he's so inciteful even
when I interviewed him it's like he
brought up a lot of points that I really
didn't even think about you won't own
the home you live in the car you're
leasing or the furniture you bought on a
credit card balance and you're still
happy because you have the illusion of
ownership but now the illusion is
starting to fall Parts what happens when
aii starts taking people's jobs away and
they can no longer service their debts
the system will forgive some of their
debts the way that student loans were
partially forgiven or the way Canadian
Banks just increased amortization even
those that save money in the bank and
the majority of asset classes are
screwed you see the governments in the
west have decided that the best thing
they can do to get out of debt at this
point is just to devalue their
currencies and pay the debt back with
dollars that are worth a lot less
ironically the assets that are the
safest from that devaluation are the
ones that feel the most unsafe and are
the most volatile when it comes to their
price here in Canada most people
invested mostly in housing instead of
stocks and businesses we seem to be
facing the bubble of all bubbles now
women are playing it safe and from what
I can tell only three things beat
inflation over the last 10 or 20 years
in this country those being real estate
Bitcoin and tech company real estate
Bitcoin and Tech are the three
Investments that have beaten inflation
that makes sense actually with what I
have seen country Canadian socks for the
most part suck except for the relatively
fat dividends they pay but there's
little to no technical Innovation here
the country is roughly 5 to 10 years
behind America with regards to Tech
Innovation you have mostly natural
resources in banking and the banksters
I'm predicting will get wiped out by
Bitcoin eventally and inflation if it
continues even women will look for
alternative assets to invest in besides
over yeah I do wonder what the future is
going to hold when it comes to currency
um our currency it's like it's so up and
down like the pound and the dollar and
every time I go to the US I'm like
shocked at how much cuz I'll go to the
US every like three or four months maybe
and every time I go back I'm shocked by
how much less I can buy than the last
time priced in underperforming mutual
funds the two women I spoke with the
other advisers and salespeople they
spoke with couldn't help them unless
they transferred millions of dollars to
them what they really meant to say is
they couldn't help themselves to the
management fees no doubts all those
single successful ladies making great
money will make a great Target for
mostly male financial advisers that will
pray on them if there's a patriarchy
it's definitely on Wall Street instead
of the local plumber with his so-called
toxic masculinity but women are too
stupid to believe it when I
remember when they complained about
there being a Spiner on the wall and I
said that spiners are usually a signed
that money will show up in the future
and they started to smile it's an old
wives tale that they were instantly
taken by because I was speaking their
language which was wishful thinking
women believe things like the way that
some children do with regards to Santa
Claus and the Tooth Fairy women believe
things the way that children do yeah
actually like I'm going to manifest my
husband that sounds like the Tooth Fairy
like that that sounds like the same
thing my MO is for helping them out
weren't 100% altruistic though one of
them is my client and the more money she
makes the more she'll be able to pay for
my services going forward it just made
me wonder how many other women were out
there like that today inheriting money
from their parents that are looking to
invest
they might be a great demographic to
Target if you're an investment adviser
anyways that's it for today thanks to
Terry for the donation and I hope you
enjoyed the topic don't forget to smash
the like button the way that these
women's bank accounts are about to get
smashed by the government on once it'll
be interesting I don't know what I think
is going to happen in the future I was I
was thinking about this do I think
eventually there's going to be a bunch
of homeless women or will the government
keep bailing them out and I don't really
have an answer but I think we can only
do this for so long until the reserves
run out until everything runs out so I
do think you're going to see an increase
in homeless women to what extent I'm not
sure um I think we're going to more of a
digital age I think you're going to see
less relationships more only fans models
but I don't I don't know we'll see we'll
see anyways guys um let me know what you
think in the comments I actually I love
Sandman he is so he is so insightful in
the stuff he brings up so make sure you
go subscribe to his channel as well like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel and I'll talk to you next
time